Now let's discuss
defenses against malware.
We will discuss intrusion
detection in another lecture.
Here, we want to focus
on Malware Analysis.
Malware analysis produces information
about a malware that can be used for
detection and response to malware.
There are 2 typical approaches
to malware analysis.
The first one is Static Analysis.
In Static Analysis, we look at
the program or the insertion set of
the malware in order to understand what
the malware would do if it is executed.
That is we want to understand what
the malware can do without actually
executing the malware.
There are limitations for Static
Analysis because some program behaviors,
in particular those that depend
on runtime or user input data,
for example conditions,
cannot be precisely
identified by looking at
the source code or binary code.
In addition,
malware code can be obfuscated.
We will come back to this point later.
Another approach is Dynamic Analysis.
Here, we run the malware program and
try to analyze its runtime behavior
to understand what the malware
is doing when it is executed.
And we can perform dynamic analysis
in different level of granularities.
For example, we can analyze the malware
execution instruction by instruction.
That's very fine-grained.
Or we can analyze the malware execution
by looking at the system calls
that the malware invokes.
So that's the so called system called
tracing, and that's coarse-grained.
There are also limitations
in dynamic analysis, because
any particular runs of the malware
only reveal behaviors of those runs.
That is, dynamic analysis cannot
provide the complete picture
of malware behaviors.
In addition, malware can try to resist
analysis by delaying execution,
input or trigger and so on.
That is, in any particular run of the
malware, the condition may not be right,
for so then triggers in the malware, and
therefore, their part of
the behaviors may not be revealed.
Even the limitations of both
approaches typically a malware
system will try to
employ both approaches.